vom muskel kerl mit bart und glatze bis
zur agilen großmutter eine agentur in
london hat sich den etwas anderen models
verschrieben
der name der agentur buckley models zu
deutsch hässliche models ag heißt nicht
dass man irgendwie speziell aussehen
muss oder eine ramponierte visage hat es
heißt dass man charakter hat dass man
sich wohlfühlt mit seinem look wenn man
schwergewichtig ist oder klein und
glücklich damit
es geht um charakter des brk 1969 sucht
die agentur für anzeige so wörtlich
interessante gesichter
seitdem ist das geschäft ein
selbstläufer allein heute stellen sich
mehr als 70 bewerber vor
die kunden der agentur sind genauso
vielfältig wie die models ein
internationales modemagazin ist dabei
ein bekanntes unterwäsche label und eine
supermarktkette die models werden für
die verschiedensten aufträge gebucht
hier haben schon firmen angerufen und
gesagt wir brauchen einen kleinen
menschen der sich selbst in den kopf
tritt das geht natürlich gar nicht uns
gibt es nicht damit menschen ausgebeutet
werden oder damit man sich über sie
lustig machen ob die bewerber heute es
geschafft haben erfahren sie erst später
sicher ist dass sie hier eine größere
chance haben als bei anderen
modelagenturen